we make way for the national league
manager of the year dave roberts of your
Los Angeles Dodgers Dave good morning
congratulations hey Dan hey I'm uh
thanks for having me on I'm trying to
get back in my car I got the fire alarms
going on when I was getting a cup of
coffee so i'm gonna try to defuse some
of this noise but hey thanks ram you
know i'm a huge fan of you okay wait
where are you right now so i i'm in
delmar right across the racetrack having
coffee with Mark Kotsay and I guess he
saw all going on outside the starbucks
though I was kind of you i was going to
enjoy my little thing watch a house i
talked to get back there and you got
fire engines behind you so it's all good
okay how did you find out that you and
one the manager of the year so yeah i
just went to the ballpark and it was
kind of one of those you know myself
dusty and joe or satellite about the
country and dusting was at his home and
jones at his restaurant i was at Dodger
Stadium and it's kind of one of those
things that will lead up and then you
get the thumbs-up and it's announced and
you know there was a lot of you know
anxiousness for me and you know
obviously against those two great
manager two men I respect them to hear
my name called very surreal very
humbling and they just kind of close the
chapter on a pretty great year for the
Dodge what were your expectations for
yourselves this year you know what I I
think for me Danny was moral I wanted to
be consistent and then my perspective my
outlook on the season and tried to stay
focused on the day-to-day and I think
that that's that's a that's a good
question i think that you know for me is
that thing I can kind of hold my hat and
for the coaches on this year and I know
that we came up shoulder falls not
winning a world championship and I get
that and that's the ultimate goal but i
think that the process straight focus
and you know to overcome adversities but
to have the guy's not laser and to be
listen stay the course I think that
that's what we did and you know even
having Kenley Jansen pitched three
innings of that last year last game in
Chicago says a lot about the character
of our guys how much do you second-guess
yourself now even after the season's
over I you know what honestly is that
the first time I really had I have to
replay the season was yesterday I really
didn't take too much time and thinking
about it man moves and things that I
might regret and I will say this that
there was a lot of scrutiny with me
taking the kid Ross stripling out his
majorly started out of a no-hitter in
San Francisco and also rich kill in
Miami out of a perfect game began the
thing I told the coaches and the players
the first day of spring training it has
got to be about the Dodgers and I think
for me to not take those guys out in
Ross never pitched that much in
professionally and rich obviously was
dealing with the blister would have
compromised you know what I was saying
it would have compromised the team so I
think that those are the two things i
would probably scrutinize the most and
if i had to do it over again dan I would
do the same thing so I think that as far
as regret there's things that I make
decisions I made that didn't work out
but that happens in any leadership role
but I really don't have any regrets
talking to Dave Roberts the Dodger
manager nationally manager of the year
hopefully there's that they put it they
stop the alarms at starbucks there and
del mar e yeah they stop the alarm so
I'm just just relax right now I'm gonna
break it and get a card in a second here
did you watch the World Series I did I I
did and you know obviously you know I
just I love the game and you know being
so close to it as far as being in the
postseason and being familiar with the
cubs and obviously having a relationship
with Cheetos so I was definitely
invested in it was great I mean it was
not only great for baseball but just
sports in general and it was a great
series and you know like I said after we
got eliminated the best team won do you
second-guess managers or manage along in
a game that you're not involved in but
you're just watching
you know what I I don't I wouldn't call
it second-guessing I think it's more of
from my lens it's more up with my
personnel what I would do in certain
situations but I think that once you
become a manager and you realize that
there's so much second-guessing going on
what you're doing and understand there's
a lot of preparation that goes into
every decision that me and the coaches
make and you've got to give other
coaches that same respect and whether
it's in baseball or in football
basketball so a quick story is it is
pretty funny again again I'm a sports
fan like you and I was talking about
black a former of management with the
rock using you're talking about football
one day and I was frustrated that it was
in September watching the football game
for one of our games and I was talking
about the play calling and he kind of
called me out a little bit fishy don't
you think that they know that they're
wanting this all Chaco play for a reason
and they're not running a flashing for a
reason and it just kind of hit me that
absolutely just hops of the quarter days
what they're trying to do so at that
point i missed a few go and it just
really hit me hard like well no duh not
going on I really that these guys know
what they're getting their the plan
you're 44 how many guys on the Dodgers
roster are you faster than all right I'm
going to start with Adrian Gonzalez I'm
faster than Adrian Gonzalez okay I gotta
go out of the bus okay for you and I we
got Adrian again and I think you and I
we've got I'm actually gonna put you in
my fame category we got your funny
grondahl and I think outside of that you
know what I don't want to get on tenley
but I think she's you and I might be
handling and I think you are dad but hey
that's about it and so beautifui is uh I
tried to rape my son and who's 16 years
old and it's funny I got him early
because I jumped the gun and then about
15 yards into the raising economy and
was winning going away so uh yeah my
days are running are certainly over and
it's
t0 my body just to a managed baseball
game all right that leads me to my final
question we have a Yankee fan who works
here one of the danettes now he's sort
of a Sox fan now but he was a die-hard
Yankee fan and I occasionally happen how
did that happen um seton how to explain
to Dave how you became a Red Sox fan
when you were a die-hard Yankee fan and
Dave Roberts made you cry when he stole
that base scene was actually those are
tears of joy of oh I hope your perfect
about you yeah okay all right now just
to make this really really painful for
him Dave could you put us put all of us
on first base with you when you steal
the base the biggest play in the
American League Championship Series
against Mariano Rivera so we're all
standing at first base with you as you
take us through the play you know what
it's one of those things where I will
take you i'll take you out there and
tito gave me a wink out there so i trot
out there and after Kevin Millar gets
his walk and I've got all these crazy
nerves went through my head and so the
bunt sign was on Sol in John's our first
base coach Scott the side from Dale
Swain the fun side I saw the bud side
and I said hey I want to steal this
space and so Lynn Jones look at tito
wiped it off dr. Swain white sign off
and so I said all right kid do what you
do so then at that point I'm i knew was
on me to steal second base and so that's
why a lot of times i could carry so much
credit for giving me the autonomy to try
to steal second base and so i get out
there and if truth be told if mo would
have went to the plate without going
over i wouldn't win on the first case
but he threw over three times at that
point I'm I was pretty locked in and I
got Maury wills my mental on one
shoulder saying doc this is what you
wanted is what you've been waiting for
and I've got the ghost of billy buckner
on my other shoulder saying you get
thrown out it's gonna be itself this is
like the tale of two you know two evils
and I'm just kind of going through it go
through it and fortunately Maury wills
uh on my left shoulder one out and it
worked out obviously graded I get the
second base and had a great jump and
dared you to go
how the heck did you just do that no it
was cold october and Billy Miller base
hit and we ended up winning it but for
me to be a part of history it was it was
special obviously and very humbling than
there is amazing yes II and we did it
huh so but she's hey here's the deal see
if I for what I hear if if dad Patrick
was closing out that game instead of
Mariano Rivera Kevin malhar wouldn't
have gone on base dan wouldn't have
walked the leadoff hitter because I
heard if it would have been this career
that he took in broadcasting and TV he
had a career with in baseball so uh
again unfortunately I couldn't play with
you I probably could have played with
you pleasure she would have been you on
the mound I don't think that Red Sox
would have won the series in 2004 huh I
was an eric gagne guy that they called
me and eric guy I was hearing Gagne
before her gun yay just to let you know
yeah so sad Chicago yeah yeah I had
goggles on yeah I had uh I didn't win a
rigaku I didn't wear a protective Cup
though because I didn't think anybody
was gonna come back or did so you what
fastball slider change or what did you
throw your straight guy yeah I just I
told you here comes cheese I actually I
i held the finger why held the one
finger down Dave I was telling the
catcher what I was throwing and the
batter that's awesome yes I think it
would have been one of the 30 boys with
Charles gate and Sybil and all those
guys that all right I don't know if I
was that bad filthy you know one of the
nasty boys I don't know if I was that
filthy about yeah hey congrats tell
Kotsay I set a low and well done
hopefully we'll get a chance to maybe
see in spring training Dave okay well
alright that's Dave Roberts the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience